hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe
sportfreunde ja die zeit vergeht wir
seien mittlerweile am start der vierten
trainingswoche mit aus dem lokal des
trainings einheit nummer 16
letzte woche freitag war noch military
fitness hohe körperliche belastung auch
für das herz kreislauf system
heute starten wir mit einem theraband
workout mit dem fokus auf den oberkörper
wir haben viele viele leistungssportler
dabei heute auch wieder einen
spezialgast journalist da ich da peter
ich bin da und die kooperative list mit
dabei leistungsschwimmerin sechster bei
der letzten europameisterschaft und
österreichische rekordhalterin über 200
meter delfin aber am besten ist gerade
da stößt die kurz davor ja also ich bin
die klage 24 jahre alt und schüler in
der südstadt und mein größtes ziel ist
es mich für die olympischen spiele in
tokio zu qualifizieren
gerade letzte woche haben wir deine
trainingspartnerin die frau rekord cala
d'or gehabt die uns gesagt hat sie
schwimmt bis zu 16 kilometer mit in der
woche sondern am tag wie viel schwimmst
du ja zum glück für mich ein bisschen
weniger weil ich 200 meter als haupt
distanz also das wären so 14 km am park
ok also immer noch ganz schön viel
das heißt bei dir ist alles
krafttraining natürlich gewichtiger
punkt in den trainingsalltag oder ein
fokus auf das wir uns erarbeitet auch
nämlich an immer wieder mit einem
widerstandsband mit einem therapeuten
oder was auch immer
ok dann die optionen sind da es ist
angerichtet macht sich bereit für tolles
workout wir starten mit einem lockeren
aufwärmen es bereits ein laufen am stand
lockeres bewegen wir bringen denn hier
hat das herz-kreislauf-system in schwung
und die farben des theraband bedeuten
natürlich angeblich unterschied im
widerstand aber im prinzip ist das ganz
egal welche farbe euer widerstandsband
hat hauptsächlich als dabei und er macht
brav mit doch mal gerne dazu bis zum
knie anheben bis man fersen dass man ab
dieser dynamik da rein kriegen immer
wieder wechseln an fersen knie heben und
dann wieder normal weiterlaufen
und ausloggen kurz wir beginnen
mobilisieren wieder bei einer heißen
blick wendung linke seite rechte seite
donnerstag die olympia qualifikation als
nächstes großes sportliches ziel dafür
fragen wieviel sekunden fehlen da also
ich bin mir zu 100 meter delfin unter
vielmehr noch 17 sekunden 1,7 sekunden
zu einer ich glaube dass wir drinnen
sein spät dass es nach dem heutigen
worker wenn man richtigen leistungs
boost glaube ich haben und blick wendung
nach oben und nach unten
das heißt auch zu carola zeiten ihr als
leistungssportler ihr wert so wie wir
regelmäßig täglich getestet nämlich
einmal an und dann dürfte im
schwimmbecken mich bewegen ja zum glück
wie dürfen dass kraft also die
kraftkammer benutzen und dann machen wir
halt kreise vor der brust
also dürften die kraftkammer gene durch
zehn jahren becken ja die
trainingsbedingungen sind perfekt zum
glück ja zwei während im block dann
konnten wir fünf wochen nicht immer
einfachen kein wasser war im zug
erscheinungen da bewegen uns wieder
locker fangen wir lernen mit hampelmann
springen die schwimmhäute bilden sich
zurück nach der lanka wasserhaus die
kiemen und geschrieben heute gehen also
ist es kleiner vor nach hinten den
wechsel arme beine ausfallschritt mit
arm heben wir werden mit euch heute 30
sekunden über machen
30 sekunden wie der pause
beziehungsweise erklären die die
natürlich wollen können gerne auch die
minute durch arbeiten es ist ja für
prima was mit dabei für triathleten mit
dabei die jetzt im lok dann vielleicht
nicht die möglichkeit haben als
leistungssportler zu trainieren sondern
zu hause im keller entsprechend sich fit
halten
was kurz aus locker und kurz ausschnitt
und am kreis und habe ich schon letzte
woche gehört ist eine der lieblings
bewegungen zum aufwärmen mindestens
hundertmal ich genau wie gesagt wir
machen ja heute nicht 100 aber wir
werden trotzdem mit einbauen
beginnen wir arme kreisen vorwärts
die schwimmerin ist schon mit dabei
nimmt gleich den ganzen körper mit immer
wieder ins knie gehen voller bewegung
aus der schulter heraus dass horne ganz
wichtig beweglichkeit im schultergelenk
und rückwärts kreisen
das heißt du schwimmst hauptsächlich den
finnen das ist der haupt disziplin und
alle anderen disziplinen kanzler war so
gut dass du uns alle wahrscheinlich
abhängen setzt oder ja ich mache die
notlagen als nebenstrecke bei der em
oder wm 400 lagers nebenstrecken okay da
erst mal alles können möchte
ok dann lockeres laufen wieder
ich habe es mit den anderen aufgemacht
um in bewegung drin waren
nachdem iris kampfsportler der gewisse
affinität haben wir machen glauben ein
boxer lauf das heißt laufen am stand mit
an strecken dazu
also waren das schwimmen immer tag
zweite karriere im boxen oder kickboxen
wäre arenen statt super aus ok dann
mobilisieren weiter ellbogengelenk und
handgelenke nacheinander zuerst ärmel
hoch geben ellbogen kreisen der kamera
langsam beginnen dann langsam mit dem
tempo bisschen variieren und die
richtung wechseln
dass dafür die trainingsstunden in der
woche kommst du schon so circa auf 30
das hängt davon ab ob wären in der nähe
also nahe zukunft der wettkampf haben
oder das hänge zusammen handgelenke
kreisen als 30 stunden woche mit ein
bisserl regeneration dazu ist ja ganz
wichtig ist in wahrheit auch folter im
job oder genauso ist es was macht in
deiner freizeit abgesehen von schwimmern
und trainieren sie lesen richtung
wechseln
klavierspielen oder ich über es gerade
sehr cool und nebenbei studiere ich noch
ein fernstudium also von zu hause aus
kann ich gut lernen super kurz aus
locker laufen wieder am stand was
studierst du ich mache den mba auf der
fachhochschule burgenland focus zukunft
ok bei der sabine beuke nachher mir als
jawohl super ausbildung
schaut euch das an einen
leistungssportler halberstadt wird bis
zum in severin mit faymann im jahrgang
nein ich bin da also auch fünfkämpfer
haben wir nämlich dort in dieser
ausbildung das zeug wirklich aussicht
dass auch anzusehen
ok also am hammer hammer
brustwirbelsäule visuelle generell mit
kreis und was machen die schwimmer am
liebsten hüfte bitte künftig reißen das
haben wir im hüftgelenk und natürlich
auch in der wirbelsäule trainer manuel
schwimmst in deiner freizeit ab ist okay
warum immer so wie hier wasserlage wie
ein stein und wir stehen in einer geht
unter oder was ok also jeder das was er
am besten heute kam
ok der makler in oberkörper vor heute
greifen mein linkes bein rechtes bein
also dynamisch im wechsel eine rotation
oberkörper drehen in der vorbeuge auch
da kann man natürlich dann das tempo
irgendwann variieren und ein bisschen
steigern und wieder aus locker kurz
ausrichten darf man wieder bisserl
diesmal mit start und stop start
bedeutet schnell laufen
stop bedeutet normal weiterlaufen
bachelot und staat
[Applaus]
start-stopp in meiner stadt
okay das lockern
das heißt wir sind schon ziemlich weit
fortgeschritten kniegelenk man eine
übung kniegelenk kreisen kreisen des
kniegelenks amare unterschiedliche
varianten kennengelernt das ist eine
davon
letztes gelenkt was uns in unserer reihe
noch fehlt das sprunggelenk machen wir
gleich wieder ins gleichgewicht mit dazu
ein weinstand knie hochheben und kreisen
im sprunggelenk handys zum gleichgewicht
halten mit wer gutes gleichgewicht auch
schon halten kann kann sich gern einmal
mit augenschließen probieren richtung
wechseln und das beweglichkeit aus dem
sprunggelenk heraus ist eines der
wichtigsten dinge beim schwimmen oder
genau für den beiden schlagen wichtig
dass man da richtig eindruck auch ins
wasser gelegt und auch davor denkanstöße
dort die gedehnte du bist ja seite
wechseln und die richtung wechseln mal
für sie bereit für den trabant workout
sie war ja ja selbst bereit dann wird
die frage schlank fangen wir mit der
ersten übung anrudern in der vorbeuge
das heißt schnappt euch eure theraband
ausgangspositionen der mahnung sagte ich
das gerne vor gut hilft breite
schulterbreit im theraband drinnen
stehen oberkörper in einer schräglage
nach vor möglichst gerader rücken und
die über umziehen nach hinten oben
ich darf dich bitten klar dass du 90
grad ich zu mir her ist dass man sich
entsprechend in der seitenansicht haben
dass man sieht wie perfekt gerade da der
rücken sein muss also man sieht dass
optimal die wirbelsäule ist in ihrem
natürlichen schwung muskulär fixiert
arbeiten tun die arme in dem fall die da
tritt selbst das heißt der arm strecke
glaube er kann sehr wichtige muskulatur
für schwimmen genau
ok dann nehmen wir uns 30 sekunden
bereitet sich vor position einnehmen
30 sekunden workout ab jetzt geht schon
los
seit man schwimmst du wann hast du zum
schwimmen angefangen seit 2006 für mich
also seid leistungsmäßig nämlich jetzt
damit sollen sechs habe ich mich beim
verein angemeldet aber mal schwimmen
lernen also wieland kostümen und
kraulschwimmen die basics und
leistungsmäßig würde ich sagen seit 2010
ok also mittlerweile also das elfte jahr
jetzt perfekt genau und auslagern 30
sekunden sind vorbei arme kurz aus
lockern
ich glaube ganz wichtig ist die
stabilität der schulbänke also
einerseits die beweglichkeit das
schultergelenk muss in allen richtungen
gut beweglich sein und auf der zweiten
seite muss es natürlich auch muskulär
fixiert sein
das heißt wir haben da eine übung für
die außen rotoren die kann natürlich in
jedes allgemeine training einbauen
aber natürlich für schwimmtraining
genauso gut das heißt übung außen
rotoren da für dich bitten einmal
vorzeigen allgemein also mit einem
bayern das verband befestigen ja in die
andere in die gegenüberliegende hand
nehmen und versuchen nach vorne zu
schauen und jeweils und den ellbogen an
die hüfte an dieselfahrzeugen und dann
versuchen aus dem schultergelenk schön
nach außen zu rotieren
denn die rotation nach außen erkennt
entweder auf dass die ära band drauf
steigen ihr könnt das aber auch mit der
zweiten hand selbst halten und fixieren
das ist genauso eine möglichkeit oder
irgendwo auf der seite einhängen
türschnalle wo auch immer das ist alles
im bereich des möglichen
30 sekunden außen rotoren werden
trainiert ab jetzt wichtige tor
weiteratmen korrigieren die position
dieser länge kürzer wenn der widerstand
zu stark oder zu schwach ist das chaos
perfekt einstellen und wichtig dabei der
elbe bleibt am körper das heißt nicht
nach hinten aus weil
sondern schöne fixierung des ellbogens
am körper sehen sie konnten kurz ausland
kann kurz schütteln die zweite variante
machen jetzt gleich mit selbst fixieren
das heißt nicht mehr drauf steigen bitte
sondern dass die ära brand in der hand
fixieren und wieder dazu nach außen kurz
vorbereiten kurz einrichten einmal
probieren ob die spannung passt ob die
fixierung passt und wenn bereits zweite
seite 30 sekunden jetzt
und wir sehen der elbe bleibt wirklich
perfekt fixiert am körper und wichtig
ist sie mit der hand rückseite nach
außen das ist nicht mit dem daumen es
nach außen ziehen oder mit dem finger
sondern wirklich mit der hand rückseite
ob jetzt faust macht die hand ausstreckt
die finger gesteckt sind ist nicht so
tragisch aber mit der handfläche nach
außen ziehen sehen sie kunden nur dann
sind die 30 sekunden schon wieder vorbei
nach fünf zeit aus okay wir haben es
vorher angesprochen die schulter
stabilität ganzer wichtiges thema aber
nicht nur für den schwimmsportler
sondern für alle rückschlag sportarten
ob das jetzt tennis spielen ist ob das
volleyball spielen ist ob das da kann
sport ist überall wo ich mit meiner
schulter über kopf vielleicht arbeiten
muss mit dem arm über kopf arbeiten muss
habe ich diese stabilität die trainieren
muss und die rotoren zu trainieren in
dieser position ist erst einmal der
wichtig ist den kann in jeder position
trainieren wir haben für euch noch eine
zweite variante heraus gefasst die
schwimmer sehr häufig trainieren weil
sie ehrlich gesagt da oben ganz für
arbeiten gerade darf die bieten dass du
uns die zweite variante dieser übung vor
zeigst genau wieder aufs theraband
steigen ja dann in die andere hand
nehmen dann noch mal die schulter und
ellbogen nach oben ziehen schauen dass
wir eine gerade linie haben geradeaus
schauen und dann im rechten winkel
die hand drauf gibt wenn du das so genau
erklären ich musste mir alle arbeiten
das heißt wichtig ist da und also der
oberarm ist parallel zum boden
die schulter ist tief das heißt die
ziehe ich nicht zur mangel hoch sollen
die bleibt tief und die rotation kommt
wie gesagt da ist meine drehachse 11
schultergelenk und da bewege mich okay
mangel bereit
der räuber lasche brav 30 sekunden für
euch arbeitszeit und los geht's den kopf
möglichst entspannt halten der sind
verlängerung der wirbelsäule
der ganze körper ist natürlich muskulär
vorgespannt das heißt nicht in eine hohe
position hineinfallen sondern mit bauch
spannung mit hochspannung arbeiten so
dass sich stabil und gut stehen kann und
in 10 sekunden seien die ersten 30
sekunden wieder vorbei
nach 321 seite wechseln kurze
ausschnitte und kurz auslaufen seite
wechseln bereitmachen 32 sekunden
startklar wieder jetzt und wie gesagt
noch einmal zur wiederholung achtet
wirklich drauf die drehachse zwischen
dem schultergelenk und dem
ellbogengelenk zu haben die bleibt
stabil und die bewegung der hand rissen
sieht wieder nach oben nach hinten und
stürzte
hier kommt perfekt in die muskulatur bei
der schulter da hinein in die
rotatorenmanschette hinein und die
stabilisierten schultergelenk und das
ist das was ganz ganz wichtig ist weil
sie konnten nach und aus kurz aus
lockern ausspannen das heißt wir haben
es dann in der vorbeuge bereits gemacht
und die außen rotoren in zwei
verschiedenen varianten eine weitere
gute übung auch für den schwimmer ist
natürlich dass street selbst ziehen
mangelt dafür bieten dass du uns das
einmal vor zeigst fixiert sich das
theraband in einem relativ knappen
abstand hände nach hinten geben
dresden besten dass man das erkennen
kann das heißt so wie wenn man mit den
fingerspitzen versucht zusammengreifen
nur das theraband da inzwischen drinnen
ist und dann streckt den arm aus genau
und wieder runter danke dritte wiederum
glaube wir haben das jetzt ganz gut
erkannt wichtig ist dass der ellbogen
stabil bleibt und sie nicht irgendwas
anderes bewegt außer der arm nach oben
30 sekunden arbeitszeit ab jetzt geht's
los
gibt's da varianten claudia die du in
deinem training magst oder bleibt die
übung gleich nah man kann zum beispiel
um das komplexe zu gestalten auch noch
den anderen arm aber nach unten zu
drücken also es ist die bewegung ist
dann gleichzeitig eine hand geht nach
oben und der andere geht nach unten also
die richtig gas geben auch schwimmsport
spezifisch da in dem bereich die übung
beide arme gleichzeitig auszustrecken
einer nach oben oder nach unten ist
natürlich genau so eine tolle option 30
sekunden arbeitszeit seien aber schon
wieder vorbei
kurz aus lockern und die seite dann
wechseln bereitmachen 5 sekunden und man
spart man mit den zweiten 30 sekunden
nach 3 2 1 los geht's entweder beide
arme gleichzeitig strecken oder den
oberen den oberen arm ausstrecken beide
varianten probiert es aus gute trainings
varianten auch hier wieder muskulär
stabil aktiv stehen bauch ist angespannt
und weiter atmend los dass sauerstoff in
den körper hinein um entsprechend da den
muskel zu versorgen dass der
leistungsfähig bleibt
30 sekunden worker zeit sind durch jetzt
haben wir eine übung die ist ab dieses
komplexe für den ganzen körper
das heißt schulter press aus der tiefen
position heraus mahnend sagt uns das
bitte mal vor dass theraband wieder
hinein steigen aktiv drinnen stehen die
spannung so wählen dass sie von unten
bereits einen leichten zug spürt das
heißt der band nach oben und dann durch
drücken einmal ganz nach oben
okay das heißt hauptarbeit mit dem
muskulatur in der schlussphase die
schulter und die belastung
du kannst die übung braucht ihn nicht
erklären du weißt du was es geht ihr zu
hause wie ist das jetzt
wir starten in 3 21 und 30 sekunden zeit
läuft da ganz wichtiger gerade in der
schlussphase der arme spaß dem bauch
anspannen die rückenmuskulatur an dass
ihr möglichst stabil aus dem rumpf ohr
stets und wieder nach unten mit den
armen und dann wieder nach oben stoßen
hochziehen und aufdrücken genau zehn
sekunden
sei es aus 30 sekunden sind durch einmal
durchschnaufen auslaufen
wer möchte trägt natürlich anschlug das
heißt flüssigkeitszufuhr ist ganz
wichtig beim training und danach starten
mit einer übung für die untere für die
unteren bereich der rückenstrecke mit
dem kreuzheben das heißt dass man die
beine ein bisschen mit dabei da ist der
rücken strecken mit dabei und ich sagt
komplexe übung mit dem theraband aber
sehr einfach umzusetzen für jedermann zu
hause gut nach über das ist einmal vor
hilft breiter stand theraband kurz
nehmen und dann sitzen der position und
versucht aufzustehen wie wenn man in
eine kniebeuge geht und gegen den
widerstand des thera band richtet man
sie auch dafür die anbieten dass du dich
90 grad mal zur kamera drehst und wir
schauen uns das an in der kniebeuge
position der rhythmisch stabil und
gerade und jetzt richtet sich der
oberkörper wieder auf und das ist die
zeit wo der rückenstrecke perfekt
arbeitet 30 sekunden macht euch bereit
in fünf sekunden start macht nach 321 30
sekunden worker zeit jetzt kreuzheben
mit dem theraband trainierst du in der
kraft kann man deine beine auch ja wir
machen kniebeugen okay ich kreuze
komplexe übungen kann man in vielen
sportarten brauchen auch beim
schwimmsport da ist ganz viel kraft mit
dabei sind nicht nur die bewegung im
wasser sondern auch sehr viel training
in der kraftkammer bankdrücken ewig
zwischenfrage alles mit dabei und für
euch zuhause willst den widerstand so
dass sie die halbe minute gut durch
arbeiten können und dann sollte muskulär
schon ziemlich belastend sein
das heißt werde nach einer halben minute
sorgt das war eigentlich nichts nimmt
ein bisschen mehr widerstand 30 sekunden
durch kurz ausland kann
nachdem er gesagt haben wir legen heute
den fokus auf schwimmen
und da ist das schultergelenk ein ganz
wichtiges und der oberkörper natürlich
auch macht man auch das diagonale
schulter ziehen aus der vorbeuge heraus
malen bitte ein
für dich vorzeigen bisschen breiter
jetzt erstand das heißt gut
schulterbreit gut über schulterbreit das
thema band überkreuzen und die arme nach
oben ziehen
wichtig dabei ist wieder der stabile
gerade rücken kopf in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule und muskulär das ganze
abgesichert das heißt die
rumpfmuskulatur ist unter spannung
position einnehmen in zehn sekunden
starten
mit dieser übung nach 543 so gerne aus
schaut das aus muskulär kommt oder schön
in den oberen rücken hinein und in den
hinteren anteil der schultermuskulatur
auch von der seite sieht man sehr schön
dass der rücken wie gesagt da perfekt
auch gerade ist wo dazu kommt und all
diese übungen können sie natürlich zu
hause jetzt machen nachmachen jederzeit
trainieren gerade die schwimmbäder haben
zu dass der band ist ein gutes mittel um
das entsprechend ab biesel zumindestens
auszugleichen und abzufedern
ok 30 sekunden haben wir wieder aus
lockern
und jetzt können wir noch inhaber
schwimm spezifische übungen hinein und
da fahren wir mal klar aber wenn man es
schon angesprochen haben mit der
beweglichkeit aus dem schultergelenk
aber bevor man die übung jetzt vorzeigen
ein wichtiger punkt langsam anfangen das
heißt nicht sofort das bewegungs maximum
herausholen ich glaube du kannst mir
bestätigen dass man im schultergelenk
nichts kaputt machen sondern einmal mit
einem breiten griff vom theraband
anfangen und einmal versuchen wo ist
überhaupt meine beweglichkeit grenze in
der schulter und langsam dann annähern
das was möglich ist sagt du mal vor eine
übung genau ungefähr schulterbreit mal
probieren dann vorsichtig nach hinten
und versuchen nicht in ellbogen zu
beugen sondern gestreckt zu lassen aus
dem wickie mit den schultern arbeiten
also gestreckt der boni wird vorschlagen
ihr zuhause probiert das einmal mit
mindestens 10 cm links rechts plus ihre
schulterbreite ja und dann bewegen wir
uns langsam in den bereich hinein und
ihr habt so einen großen vorteil jetzt
dass der band ist beweglich ist
dynamisch lässt sich auseinander ziehen
das heißt
in der position drauf kommt es war viel
zu kurz gegriffen künstler natürlich
muskulär dadurch soll das ganze
ausgleichen und versucht einmal jeder in
seinen bewegungsradius fünfmal nach vor
fünf mal zurück um da an der
beweglichkeit zu arbeiten
kontrolliert immer wieder dass der
ellbogen gestreckt ist und keine beuge
drinnen hat genau vor und zurück vor und
zurück und wir kommen einer gute
mobilität und beweglichkeit im studio
gelenk hinein übung hammer was machst du
also kein schwimm- spezifischer schwimm
spezifisch viele es in einem ort wie
kriegen wir das am besten hin
für das grauen das wäre dort zum
beispiel klassische übung ja dazu müsste
man das thema bahrain hängen oder man
hatte also zwischen alle quasi in der
partner hält ist die ära band genau und
wir versuchen die vorbereitungsphase zu
simulieren das heißt im ersten teil der
zug phase beim schwimmen hoher album und
stabiles handgelenk sie zurück aber die
klar da kann es sicherlich noch viel
besser erklären was muss man achten dass
man muss sie konzertiertes der ellbogen
oben bleibt und nicht christen zug
anfang okay und schauen dass man die
hand zum bauchnabel und so stark ist mir
eine kleine korrektur her auch in der
position genau ist der gerade rücken
absolut wichtig und auch das müsse immer
achten
ok dann würde vorschlagen 30 sekunden
statt nur los mit der rechten hand 30
sekunden erste zug vase darin schwimmen
und geht's los und wir selbst bleibt
hoch der oberkörper bleibt stabil bleibt
gerade das heißt nicht nachgeben nicht
hinein drücken wenn man sie es ein
bisschen schwieriger machen möchte
könnte mal die hand aufziehen
ja also unterschiedlichste varianten
sind da auch drinnen erste zug phase
beim schwimmen sehen sie konnten noch
und wie jetzt fragst du bleibst du in
deiner schwimm position und wechselt nur
die hand oder fuß hand wechseln
und natürlich kennt sie auf die
einarmige zug phase ja das wäre man dann
gleich sehen auch in die 2
dann wechseln kein problem korrigiert
sich immer wieder bleibt der rücken
stabil und gerade volle belastung auch
für die rückenstrecken der position fünf
sekunden aufrichten auslagern gesetzt
selbst für eine geübte schwimmerin die
im wasser bin immer sicher wie ein brett
liegt ohne irgendwo ein problem mit der
wasserlage zu haben ist als an land oft
gar nicht so gar nicht so einfach diese
position auch muskulär abzusichern und
das zu machen und da muss man sich
einfach permanent ständig kontrollieren
am besten vor einem spiegel stellen und
dann mal schauen ist mein rücken
überhaupt muskulär abgesichert in der
richtigen position
okay das war die erste zug phase wie
schaut's aus gibt es für die weitere
zukäufe nach eigenen übungen da müssen
wir wieder hin die türschnalle dürfen
alle oder einen partner der held genau
da man alle so lieb und also hält das
der apa nach ihrem rücken
ausgangsposition ob in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule haben nach hinten durch
stand dazu geht nach hinten und schauen
mal linke seite thema rechte seite und
worauf kommt es an dass man beim
durchstrecken nicht nach oben strecken
will sondern eher nach hinten sich
drücken will den trizeps durch strenge
hat die letzte druckphase kommt aus dem
arm strecke aus dem tritt selbst heraus
ganz wichtig und das kennt sie zu hause
natürlich perfekt nach trainieren und
entsprechend dann mit einem
leistungsvorteil wieder ins wasser gehen
waren die schwimmbäder dann wieder
geöffnet sind zweite seite 10
wiederholungen
noch 5 4 nach 3 noch zwei und eine
letzte ist unterschlagen worden aber ist
okay ja also ungefähr 130 sekunden das
zeit anhalt her nimmt oder so 10 bis 15
wiederholungen dann sagt schon mal ganz
gut dabei wichtig ist dass es muskulär
anstrengend ist und dass es aber mit dem
körper recht stabilisieren können das
bringt doch nichts wenn solche in alle
richtungen verbiegt weil das wasser gibt
daneben lag
und dann hat man schlechte wasserlage
das heißt da muss man wirklich schauen
dass man aus darum spannung heraus
seinen körper zu hundert prozent stabil
hält eine übermacht man ja und ich im
märz an delfinen des jahres würde das
mit beinamen du würdest es mit beiden
auch noch machen eine variable unter uns
die viel rückenschwimmen gibt es dann
eine übung natürlich dann zeigen sie
bitte auch noch ist man der meinung war
habe ich damit machen ja da steigt also
wieder aus der bahn steigen und dann
beim rückenschwimmen ist es wichtig mit
dem kleinen finger hinter den kopf
einzutauchen oder am ohr vorbei dazu
haben wir den rücken zu
das mit gestrecktem arm von der position
vor dem körper bis über den kopf und der
kleine finger gleitet quasi die bewegung
ein und zieht nach hinten
auch da wichtig rücken oberkörper bleibt
stabil in der position dreht nicht mit
sondern bleibt in seiner position stabil
muskulär abgesichert seite wechseln
zweite seite noch mein name zehn
wiederholungen
und er setzt nicht nur die beweglichkeit
aus dem schultergelenk ist wichtig
sondern ich brauche eine gewisse kraft
um entsprechend schwimmen zu können um
im wasser auch vorwärts zu kommen
abgesehen natürlich von der technik ich
glaube drei wiederholungen haben wir
noch sehr gut eine halbe stunde
theraband workout mit unserem spezial
gast da claudia hufnagel ist ab
trainiert sozusagen gerade was möchtest
du den leuten zu hause noch mitgeben ja
vielleicht ist es wichtig zu der zeit
sich eine routine einzubauen dass man
jeden tag nach dem aufstehen zehn
minuten patera barren übung gemacht sich
dehnt dass man guten start in den tag
hat das haben wir schon gehört vom
unseren stocker vom korporal wagner
werkzeug hat aus dem japanischen heraus
jeden tag jedes gelenk einmal durch
mobilisieren und durch bewegen genau das
verstärken wir damit sehr gut das heißt
jeden tag ein bisschen bewegen
mobilisieren japan trainieren oder
einfach unser werk hat mitmachen da sah
man von super weg um wirklich fit aus
dem lokal zu kommen
ich sage danke für heute morgen dienstag
macht man einen rucksack workout das
heißt wir simulieren damit eine kette
bälle weil man davon ausgehen dass die
vielleicht nicht jeder zu hause hat das
heißt ein rucksack zwei drei bücher
hinein und dann können wir morgen in ein
intensives körperliches training wieder
staaten danke für heute und wir freuen
uns auf das morgige training